Hi, and welcome to AlphaBits.
AlphaBits is an outlet for our inquisitive minds.
We can't stop experimenting with new technology, and
we wanna share what we're playing with with
you. We're your hosts, Brian and David. Hi.
I'm David, defender of the Rawkode Academy. I'm
a perpetual learner, always playing with new cool
tools that I'm gonna share with you as
part of this podcast. And I'm Brian. I'm
a developer advocate at Amazon,
and I love all the shiny new toys
in tech.
It's kind of my passion is is testing
out the new stuff and,
seeing what's cool. Okay. So I'm in a
project that is a
Hugo blog.
And what I intend to do is
make Hugo available
in only in this directory. So, if I
ask which Hugo
see, don't have one. So, I'm gonna do
is aqua init
and that creates the YAML file.
Alright. So, it's it's set the registry. So,
this is a pin version of
the package registry that shows which packages are
available and what versions of those packages are
available. So, I'm gonna search for
Hugo.
And, it brings up a a fuzzy finder
like search interface. So, I'll type Hugo.
And, I get
two choices.
Basically, Hugo extended and Hugo.
So, I'll just pick Hugo
and it outputs this
item, array item for YAML. So, let's
mini our
aquapro thing.
And paste in the
output.
So Hugo version zero dot one one seven.
Save it.
The aqua
I. Now, type it Hugo.
I've got a Hugo.
I move up a directory.
Still there,
but I could choose a different version in
a different directory if I wanted to.
Now, PewDie, it works,
and I'm good to go.
You can include that vocab.
So you would include this in your
git repository
so that any person that was using this
would automatically
get the same configuration.
So that's at the project level.
At the
global level,
there's also another config file that you can
use for globally available tools.
So, if you look at my globally available
aqua yaml,
I have the git hub CLI, fuzzy finder,
and NeoGIMM installed.
So,
it's pretty wicked. I mean, you could use
this
to get a very repeatable
environment,
but it's it's very much focused on CLI
tools, CLI applications binaries
as opposed to libraries.
Nice. So it's pretty slick with let's say
I wanted to
search for cargo.
So I could just do aquaproj,
and there is no cargo in here. How
about Rust?
Rust analyzer. So I could add the the
Rust analyzer if I wanted,
probably because Rust itself is such a
large install.
Is there?
Let's see.
Yes. It is. So
try.
We can add it.
Because I'm at the global level, I have
to specify this dash a. So it will
be included in the global.
So now I can which I'll try it.
I could spell.
That's weird. I swear it said
085.
But come try reports
084.
Strange.
That's probably me. I probably forgot to update
version string somewhere, but I'll look into it.
Possibly.
Alright. So that's aquapro. It's
short and sweet, but pretty powerful if you
want to
do some version pinning of particular tools
at both the global and project level and
share that with your team.
Yeah.
Awesome.
I'm assuming their registry is just a GitHub
repository that anyone can go along and contribute
to. Is. Yes. So
if you go to aquaproj,
let's stop this screen, add a different.
Alright. So here's their
GitHub org. You can see the aquaproj thing
itself. It's got an installer
and the registry,
and the registry has
all of the package definitions.
And and when I first looked at aquapro
roughly a year ago, it had 30 or
40.
But now it's it's gotta be well into
the thousands.
So they have pretty much anything you need
in terms of binary. So you can see
the definition,
the registry metadata,
and
this is how it knows how to get
things out of GitHub.
And then the package metadata.
That's Starship version one dot 16 dot zero.
Nice.
Very cool. So that's what I got. Alright.
So this is
a rather contrived application of a build pipeline.
It's a back end go app.
It just has, like, some really simple endpoints,
like slash ping slash ask, which speaks to,
you know, the OpenAI chat GPT.
You place in a question, it gives you
a response. That's it. Nice and simple.
Reason I set up like this is because
I wanted it to use an API token
and a secret to show how that worked
with the Dagger build pipeline. So it doesn't
need this environment variable to exist, and we'll
see how we make that work or at
least how we satisfy that with the Dagger
pipeline.
I'm always
making sure that I have my build instructions
as close to my application as possible. So
you'll see here that in the back end
directory and I know the sidebar is always
really small and the s code, but, you
know, we have a build directory with a
Google some Google code called build.com.
And this is our Dagger pipeline.
So all of these publicly exported functions
are things that can be consumed or used
by a general purpose build tool.
And and we'll see the general purpose part
in a moment.
But we see here that we have export,
which is gonna call another step, build container
image, and then publish it to my GitHub
registry.
The build thing itself,
we can ignore the runtime caller. This is
just me doing some weird directory juggling.
But we get this Dagger client where we
say that we want a container.
Remember, we're gonna use Golang latest as a
base.
And we add our current directory
to slash source within the container.
We set our work there, and then we
say web exec. So we don't execute the
command inside of this container.
These five instructions
are pretty much just a Docker file. Right?
I'm building
Yeah. Container image or potentially it could be
building a container image.
All I'm doing is running go build,
outputting a binary code back end and telling
that that the source is main dot go.
So now I've taken the instructions to build
my application and made them available as a
function within a Dagger pipeline.
We then actually build the container. So this
is like a multi stage container file or
Docker file.
Only this time when we ship it to
prod,
yeah, I wouldn't normally use Ubuntu 22, but,
you know, whatever. Let's ignore that for now.
We do an app update. We install the
CA certificates.
We grab a file from an alternative build
step. So here, we're actually using the output
of this build as a variable and
grabbing a file from anywhere inside of the
container, which is just our source back end
binary.
We set an entry point and then that's
just got a container image.
And
that's it. You don't know this GraphQL. You
don't know that it's a container based build
plane. You don't really know that it's Dagger
other than that, you know, we have an
import for some Dagger stuff.
So I just find this a really nice
API to define how to build any application.
Now I could run this with go run,
but because it's a model repository, least it's
a thick, can try it model repository in
this case. I wanted to have, like, a
centralized build instruction. So I've got the choice.
Right? As a developer, I can build a
small isolated part, which is just the back
end, or I could just say go run
everything and build the things that have changed.
Because this is build cut under the hood
and we're only mounting end specific things to
each step, I can really take advantage of
the way that build cut and container caching
works.
So I could point it down the time
on a repository with thousands of projects, but
if one file is changed, it'll build to
one thing, the thing has changed then and
any dependence thereof. Okay. Which is very neat.
So this build directory at the top level
now, so outside of back end
It's configured using a go workspace,
which is my new favorite feature in a
go, which means I can do local references.
So I've got some helpers here.
We have a function called get database with
config and get database.
So this is the explicit one that does
some configuration, and this is one that just
injects a little bit of an override. So
here, I'm just saying we default to d
b 15 or postgres 15,
but you can't provide the full config if
you want. And then we just set it
up so that we can access Postgres as
the user Postgres with the password Postgres.
This function isn't available for me to use
anywhere. Same with secrets.
This is actually just gonna do a local
exec where it uses the one password CLI
to grab a secret and then spits it
back as a secret value.
And then we have our different entry points.
In this case, test is orchestrated with main
dot go, which uses go workspaces to build
in the back end builder,
set up to Dagger client. So now we
do know that Dagger's a thing.
We use our Google Workspace dev tool project
to grab the secret.
We get our database
and then we just call a few more
things. Right? So I'm saying here's the build
container image that we've seen. Well, with this
time, I'm gonna change a few things. I'm
gonna pass in the environment variable for the
database. I'm gonna pass in the secret token,
some port information. We can do service bindings
so that the different containers
can speak to each other if you want.
So in a way, you can actually use
Dagger just to replace Docker Compose completely, which
is very cool as well. Now there's a
small hurl test suite here. So once we
built the image, we actually just run it
or at least we use a surface binding
in this case. And then we run another
container that has hurl available, which is like
a
HTTP testing framework because it's a really simple
syntax.
And then we run the test against it,
and then we can inspect the output of
that and say, hey, this passed or this
failed and then show you why it failed.
The HARL file looks like this. Sorry. HARL
file looks like this. We wanna have the
ping endpoint and then we have the ask
endpoint, which will actually go and speak chat
GPT.
So there's a lot of code and fed
over that really, really quickly. I'm gonna show
you it running and you have any questions,
I'll I'll take them. So there's two ways
to do this. One is, as a go
developer, you could just do go run where
we do build test main.
We get that a few seconds.
One password prompt.
That was an error. Of course, that was
gonna happen. Right?
Make sure I'm on the right account.
That's fair.
Oh, here we go. Okay. And my test
passed.
Of course, never trust the passing test. So
let's see. We change this to Brian. Run
that again.
So let's see if it fails, it'll tell
us why it failed. We'll that output from
Huddl. And then there's one last thing I'll
show you and we'll wrap this up. Alright.
Now it's saying we got back hello in
German. It's hello. I couldn't tag and we
expected to find Brian. So let's change that
back. Now I have to remove an alias
because this is a very experimental feature of
Dagger where they now provide an experimental UI
where you could do Dagger run and then
see go run
build test main. Now what this does
is it will actually run a Dagger client
for you, which executes your command, but allows
you to visualize the entire graph of containers
and commands are running within the build instance.
So here, we'll actually be able to see
that most things are probably cached. I've run
it a few times,
but we can see all of the jobs
spawning and the output as we progress.
So you got all these, like, fancy get
branch symbols. Let's say, okay. Here's your directory.
Now we gotta pull an image. Here's Golang,
and you can see all these adults jumping
about. But it really gives you good visibility
into what's happening within your build pipeline.
Yeah. So that's Dagger. Nice.
So
where is where's the passing?
How do you know it passed?
It isn't obvious that
Well, it's all cash. What's it look like?
Well, it's
it's cached right now. It's somewhere in Oh,
it it was way at the top. I
see it. Was it?
Oh, yeah. Okay. Right. Okay. Right. But this
is all have been cached. So cached, cached,
cached, cached, cached, cached, cached, cached, the way
down. So actually, it really didn't execute anything
because nothing had changed.
If we change this again,
hello, blah blah blah, whatever. Something just invalidate
the cache.
And we'll actually see that one of the
steps is no longer cached and that'll be
the hurl test suite itself.
Because that's what we changed. Right? We changed
the hurl test file. Yeah. There we go.
This one actually executed this time and then
we got our failure. Oh, wow. Alright. I'm
impressed. Yeah. It's nice that you can raise
some go code, some TypeScript code, some Python
code, some Rust code, some Alexa codes, you
know, and theory could support any language.
Some languages are obviously better suited than than
others.
First of the most
first and most importantly, pick one that you're
comfortable with, but then after that, try and
pick the one that's gonna give you the
the best pipeline. Like, been able to reuse
functions across a mono repository is a really
important skill, but not every language actually supports
that terribly well,
like, no JS, unfortunately.
The Go with Go Workspace does enable that
kind of per user pipeline.
Very impressive. I could think of a few
uses for Dagger. Alright. Well, hopefully people enjoyed
this episode. We'll see you all next week.
Cheers. If you wanna hear why we showed
off these tools, check out the podcast available
at alphabets.fm.
Until next week. See you soon.